lo que se busca con este tipo de
acciones dirigidas a priori contra
objetos que no tienen que ver con la
crisis climática
bueno Muchas gracias por por la
invitación
hay que interpretar este fenómeno como
en la dimensión que se debe primero hay
que entender que ninguna de las obras
fue dañadas porque tenían evidentemente
un cristal que las protegían este
impacto no es material Entonces si no es
un impacto simbólico y tiene que ver con
Cómo nosotros estamos teniendo nuestra
escala de valores como sociedad y la
falta de interés y de responsabilidad de
la política partidista y de la política
internacional para afrontar la crisis
climática y ecológica entonces no es un
activismo versus el arte porque de hecho
el arte ha sido históricamente un
hermano hacia mes de las
transformaciones sociales y los
activismos en busca del cambio social
sino que tiene que ver con llamar la
atención para que se posicione en el
debate público y político la urgencia de
las políticas climáticas y las políticas
ambientales y se exige una
responsabilidad de parte de los
tomadores de decisiones para afrontar
con realismo las pérdidas y daños y
encaminarnos
tenga una transición de la economía
hacia una economía que sirva a las
personas y respete la vida y este tipo
de acciones este tipo de llamados de
atención forman parte de un análisis
concreto de la situación global o cada
región necesita de un tipo de acción
acorde a su realidad político social
y bueno evidentemente el cambio
climático es un fenómeno geopolítico y
los informes del ipcc y los diversos
informes científicos nos demuestran que
están poniendo en jaque la calidad de
vida y las condiciones de vida digna de
las personas y en general del futuro
evidentemente esto como es un fenómeno
político hay que entender que hay una
responsabilidad compartida pero
diferenciada no el sur global que ha
sido ha sido el el menos causante de
esta crisis climática y sin embargo va a
ser la región la región es más afectadas
en su global entonces evidentemente las
políticas que se habilitan deben ser
contextuales pero implica una gestión
desde las relaciones internacionales y
desde las dimensiones geopolíticas
porque es un fenómeno global que implica
una articulación de las políticas
internacionales y las políticas
económicas para que se pueda asimar con
realismo el cambio climático y centrando
la mirada en América Latina qué
situaciones son más apremiantes a la
hora de luchar contra una crisis
climática aquí en la región
bueno en general la particularidad de la
región es el tema de la desigualdad que
vimos como como región el cambio
climático no tienen los mismos efectos
en todos los sectores de la población
sino que es diferente no es lo mismo
recibir el cambio climático un
departamento con aire acondicionado que
una choza con techo de zinc Entonces
evidentemente el gran desafío de la
región latinoamericana es articular una
gestión de políticas de transición
ecológica con una con unas políticas de
disminución de la desigualdad para que
estos impactos tengan
una una menor intensidad en sectores
históricamente excluidos y podamos
generar unas políticas de Justicia
climática